can you in constant bug's voice tell us
about when you lost your virginity yes
oh my God yes yes a good question
well I had a baby carrot then it grew
into an adult-sized carry
[Music]
all right everyone welcome back to a
very very special segment of the hot
seat because today we have in the hossy
mister Eric Bowser
[Applause]
seat is hot so just so you know uh
you've been in a hot seat before I have
not been on a hot seat in a while I have
a very cold ass so I'm ready for this so
basically we're just gonna fire some
questions at you obviously we might get
a little bit steamy but before we do
that we're going to start extremely dry
and cold with our man over there Mr
barquan all right hello hi and what's up
bud uh nothing much
if you could make a sand castle
of any tragic event which one would it
be quick
uh I would have to say the Titanic
um very good choice I was kind of oddly
oddly obsessed with uh the Titanic as a
kid I don't know the movie well uh
especially the movie
but uh Billy Zane you know I love Billy
Zane I'm a huge Billy Zane fan
um not a Leo fan but a Billy Zane that's
who you like Billy Zane in a wig always
that's the first time I saw titty at a
theater
I think mine was uh Tango and cash with
my mom and my aunt of all people it was
gross my cousins took me to the theater
and I saw tits and they were like what
are we gonna tell his parents but this
is about you let's go yeah yeah uh it's
quite the hot seat question but yeah I I
remember getting this book as a kid and
it was like the the details of the
Titanic and what had happened and I was
like should I be reading this it's kind
of tragic
um but I just remember the images
and it was like very Tastefully done
like oil painting like images of the
events of the Titanic Oh the painting of
an iceberg the crashes yeah the Cry of
people like in lifeboats and kids and
women and and people in the water and
long before the movie came out and I was
just like
I was just so fascinated by it by people
dying and drowning yeah oh wow it's
really weird you're in the uh like voice
acting field which I think you know for
and for a lot of people that's already
outside of the normal like um
traditional job rights like not engineer
or doctor whatever as a kid what was
your dream job
I think it was I I knew at least uh at
least by the eighth grade uh that I
wanted to work in animation
how did you even know that was a job
eighth grade well because I remember
getting the uh this book and again it
was not the Titanic book I'm moving away
from tragedy to uh to the it was like
the art of Disney and it it profiled
almost every
piece of Animation from like you know
um like even the old school black and
white one the one with the dinosaur I
always forget the name that's that's how
much of it The Land Before Time even
before that the ver I think it was like
Gertie the dinosaur or something and it
was like the very first time we ever saw
like a moving animated image and it was
like from that all the way up until like
uh Beauty and the Beast I think was the
the movie it was like Little Mermaid
then this was like the modern one at the
time that was the one because I remember
the next year they released the same
book but like with like Aladdin or
whatever so I remember just seeing
images of people at their desks and like
you know they would be in a room like
this and they would be with like a
pointer stick kind of like going through
storyboards definitely couldn't have
been a room like this it was very
similar to a room like this and uh you
you you would be surprised how many
times you've probably driven by an
animation studio or sound recording
studio in this city and not even known
it was there the whole time uh but yeah
I I remember looking at that book and
going oh wow there's there's grown-ups
you know like making this stuff and I
always thought that was probably what I
I'm going to do when I'm older but I
didn't know how I was gonna get into it
or how it would lead to voiceover I that
was so you knew it was like the industry
you wanted to get into but you didn't
know what specific job right so it's
like I could draw I could do this I
could do that yeah because most people
would know like go to school for
theatrical dramatic arts if you want to
be an actor I didn't know that I didn't
I didn't know like to be a voice actor I
didn't know that's you know it all
starts with good acting so what if I
could do wacky voices
that gets you to the door but what keeps
you in the room is the good acting the
believability of this character that
you're trying to portray when when did
you know you were good at animation and
drawing uh as a kid I was always the one
in class where everyone if there was a
project that involved art or drawings I
would always be the one where other kids
would be like can you draw this for me
you were that kid I'll give you a
Twinkie if you draw this clearly I work
with Twinkies but um but yeah it was
even teachers they were like can you can
you draw the the program can you I did a
caricature soliciting your skills
Adventures teachers before grade these
papers long before art teacher before me
too movement uh I was being abused by
teaching no I'm just kidding I had
nothing but support from my teachers
growing up as a kid even in high school
like almost everyone has like a bad
experience in either elementary school
or high school or college I've had
nothing but pure luck when it's come to
you know people knew that I was
distracted easily but instead of
scolding me for that that they would say
go do the morning announcement so I
would do the announcement is that public
schools yeah Catholic public school wow
you were just doing a wacky voices
all the time I was making fun of
teachers I was wow that's so cool
valedictorian in high school and I
should have not there were like so many
but because they liked your voice
they're like do we want to be bored by
like a couple nerds are like entertained
by this kid and they picked me and I was
doing like impressions of all the
teachers and stuff and I don't know it
was it was wild whatever sorry is was
did you ever do a talent show or like
anything like that I was always hosting
like those shows like for assemblies and
school functions and stuff I was always
making videos there's there's you know I
have them all still on VHS like I was
editing and shooting video and yeah you
know like there's always a kid we always
knew a kid in in school that did that or
gravitated towards it I imagine that's
what you guys you know you guys are
entertainers you guys are all the same
we're we're all freaks here so um
we we copied just people we knew but you
copied the greatest well I mean but
still you're here I
by the way I'm I'm a guest here I'm not
the host so I feel like how did we even
get Bugs Bunny here because man you you
someone said you'd pay me in Olympia so
I'm like still waiting for that right
Bart what the hell dude my mom's coming
soon to bring it uh where did you grow
up uh Scarborough so Scarborough Ontario
this is where uh Mike Myers came from
John Candy uh Drake uh wow this is the
difference between a Canadian upbringing
and an American upbringing what's the
difference
life is nicer look at his teachers are
nice oh yeah no one's beating his ass
every day true yeah maybe I don't know
like I'm sure there's some amazing
people here and I mean look you know
again we're looking at you guys from our
our point of view in America yeah we're
we're did you grow up big America was
batshit crazy yes
I know though I know yeah but I live
here I live here I don't live I've lived
the last 15 20 years here so so when
have you used your impression skills
that got you in trouble
oh in trouble uh in trouble in trouble
um probably like
prank calls I guess uh that's so good
you know when does that even exist
anymore I was a huge fan of the Jerky
Boys if you guys remember yeah
that's that's in that same era I
remember that I remember Paul yeah
did you did did you do a lot of prank
calls growing up oh yeah all the time oh
man I love those I mean just I wasn't
wasn't specifically a voice I guess it
was just like any any anything I did
them as yourself yeah
he just likes prank calling Eric is that
you yeah yeah I mean I guess but I don't
even remember a time where I was caught
for doing that and got in trouble that's
okay I might have to might have to come
back and think about that
it's a very interesting question gotten
in trouble hmm has there ever been a
time where you're like man I don't want
to keep doing this this job worth this
oh man for me like I think and and you
guys can agree it's like this industry
will never tell you to stop or take a
break it's almost like you can't right
because as soon as you stop it's someone
else is gonna do it oh yeah it feels
like you're always not doing enough
right yeah but again you guys are like
it's the wild west right now it's
self-sustained you have like amazing
equipment in here you guys have amazing
editors and like production value and
stuff and and no one's telling you to
stop right it's like you know we we
burnt out and then we fell off oh wow
yeah that's what happened [ __ ] we've
been online for about 16 years man with
no breaks no brakes yeah and no one just
break up I'm not complaining it's
[ __ ] hilarious exactly I mean we get
to do what we love for a living and this
is my break from my other things that I
do now right so this used to be my main
thing but now it's like I've done I do
other things I come here and I'm like
thank God I'm here with you guys I think
that's the ultimate Doom right is like
when you start feeling like and this is
how it started feeling at the animation
job that I had was I felt like the you
know like the lettuce guy at Taco Bell
like someone would hand me a taco and
I'd be like okay here's the lettuce
here's just hand it to the Tomato guy
and that's kind of how animation felt
because I was the guy that was you know
I would get a script and a storyboard
and I would have to draw like the final
poses of someone one and then hand that
off to an animator and they would make
that character move very assembly line
almost yeah and that's what I miss the
most about working in animation is the
camaraderie right it's being around
people that like all we would do is you
know you know like
like get trashed uh on Fridays and like
show up to work late leave late uh send
each other dumb videos over chats you
know you're at this desk for like eight
hours drawing negotiate the deadline
overall yeah oh my God go get a coffee
break so this is the 10 minute 52 second
uh portion of the video where we start
turning up the heat on our questions and
stuff like that I know Chris has got a
really great question of course she does
have a good one for you have you ever
used your voices in the bedroom in the
bedroom like what do you mean like uh
when I make my bed in the morning yeah
That's all folks
can you do that can you do that I mean
uh I mean my volcano blue
I might not ever use that voice again
but uh
um and you are recording it that's good
there's three cameras here and the phone
oh I mean Porky's that we both only wear
a jacket with nothing else underneath
and a bow tie no pants
that's how folks to the ladies yeah but
um
I don't think I have and I think that
you know no one's ever asked you ever no
never never I haven't dated anyone that
uh that kinky or that daring uh uh so
you never had an animation groupie
um and they're like oh do the voice
yeah animations right away super wet
yeah yeah yeah right away obviously with
my my first answer of um obviously maybe
I have but it was never like like that
it was never like hey can you do the
voice while I'm you know
if anyone ever ask you when I'm about to
harambe
has anyone ever asked you to do a voice
that doesn't exist like oh can you
please do the Wiley Coyote voice yeah
and that'll be like
yeah
I'm just draw it out for them has there
been a time that you were super
frustrated that you couldn't get the
voice right
yes yes yes yes yes I mean again like uh
Miley coyote I would say well
bugs but also like
uh I was like uh 2012 they rebooted
Ninja Turtles and I was uh uh maybe the
third or fourth person to voice Raphael
in the pilot oh wow and then later
they're like well you know we we really
enjoyed you know and I also did like a
live event like all the things were
leading up to like me voicing Raph and
then I got uh switched out oh last
minute with this uh young actor by the
name of uh Sean Aston I don't know if
you've heard of this guy uh he was in
Lord of the Rings uh he was Mikey from
Goonies he's a very famous actor oh yeah
and uh a super nice guy and did a hell
of a job as Raphael
um but you're like [ __ ] this guy but he
wasn't like you gotta know what a
crumpet is to understand Cricket yeah
yeah
that that's like one of my favorite
versions of Raph is the live action I
don't like the new Ninja Turtles how
they changed them I like the surfer guys
that I grew up with right the classics I
mean I think that they have to change it
I guess because
you know
I'm gonna get like more business in a
sense where like they want to make new
toys they want to make stuff different
they have to keep and like Taylor Swift
right they have to keep
Reinventing or whatever to kind of
maintain those rights or to to kind of I
don't know just to keep things different
I'm gonna disagree with you because they
didn't do that to Mikey I mean Mickey
Mickey you invented Mickey Mouse no but
like they didn't [ __ ] make okay so
the difference is they kept Mickey cute
they didn't make Mickey all buff and
[ __ ] with veins popping out looking all
weird and [ __ ] like that's what they did
to the Ninja Turtles Ninja Turtles they
were cute cool ninjas man and then they
put them on steroids what the hell is
going on they don't believe they don't
belong in a [ __ ] uh super jacked they
don't like a it's a bodybuilding show
now well yeah again well they're mute
mutants right so like they might have
they might have mutated into bigger
better you know but they look like a
throbbing boner I don't like that I just
want to see a Ninja Turtle
how different yeah a flash of turtle how
different was that other guys wrap to
yours well uh definitely I loved his
performance Sean's performance as ref
because he has that
kind of naturally kind of gruff kind of
husky sounding voice you know and that's
kind of the attitude that they were
aiming for for that character and it was
natural you know what I mean I may have
been putting actually I I think this is
actually one of the notes was that at
the time Jason Biggs from American Pie
was voicing Leo and my voice my natural
voice print was kind of similar to his
that edge kind of sound and I was trying
to be a little bit more Gruff and and
act in a different way which was
different from how he was acting yeah
your voice does sound like Jason bass
voice but at the end of the day the edge
of my voice sounds a lot similar to his
they wanted something different yeah and
if you listen to Sean Aston he has like
this really kind of the way he talks is
so much different then but but it's
funny because he Jason Biggs ended up
getting switched out with Seth Green
which later was so different from
everyone else so again it's sometimes
you can't get mad at not getting a voice
because it's not really politics it's
just how the chemistry works and all
that stuff and even with bugs like I
auditioned for bugs and it was literally
10 years had gone by until they
auditioned him again and then that's
when I booked it so I think uh if there
are young voice actors and performers
out there it doesn't have to be voice
it'll come around when one door closes
three open oh we got to turn up the heat
even more because I feel like this is
just a very it was a disappointing
answer for you I'm sorry okay I'm gonna
lie and say all the ladies I've dated
I've done so many voices in the sack
that you know I can't even have an
erection now without going yeah
he passed around a lot on Twitter
tomorrow you could say no but um but I'm
sure you won't say no can you in
constant bug's voice tell us about when
you lost your virginity yes oh my God
yes that's a good question I mean you do
have a son so we're pretty sure yeah you
can't lie yeah it's a story that you can
tell him just use euphemisms yeah well I
had a baby carrot then it grew into an
adult-sized Kitty and then I'll stop
there I have to I want to keep the job
I just I feel like I just got here
I mean they'll let me say that and then
okay I'll get anything further yeah I
will oh yeah oh boy I was like have you
um ever dealt with like having to tell
your parents what you do for a living
and then like them just like being what
is that well you know I think at the
beginning they were like so you're gonna
do what you know you can draw cartoons
all day
again they they they knew what kind of
kid I was growing up and I I don't think
it was a surprise and I was also very
nurtured by um uh an uncle my my mom's
eldest brother who was like the first
family member on that side to immigrate
from the Philippines to like Canada and
he was like it's it's too [ __ ] cold
here so he moved he moved to L.A and he
passed away like last year unfortunately
but he was the guy that was like always
sending me clippings of like hey look at
this like come to L.A yes always and I
have all those clippings still and uh
it's crazy like newspaper clippings L.A
times I was always like he would date it
and like you know send a couple bucks if
he could and just be always like the guy
that was like hey you're gonna move here
one day and you're gonna work in this
industry and it wasn't even like a
question wow did he work in an industry
or what did he do he worked in like real
estate and uh you know owed the IRS a
lot of money
[Laughter]
agents have you ever been approached to
do a voice acting job that you were like
either not down for or uncomfortable to
do or ah yes yes yes if you uh if you
like uh Japanese hentai oh I love it
holy [ __ ] for real yeah he does all the
girls if you just click back on your
browser uh to what you were watching
yesterday it's probably me uh no no uh
just other other roles that uh you know
maybe like uh unspoken might should be
done by a certain person Whoever has
held it the longest
you know but at the end of the day as
performers you can't
it's not up to us as actors who decides
who plays who you know it's it's up to
the people producing it and and writing
the stories and directing the stories
and who are casting these roles that
make those decisions so yeah there's
there's definitely been you know rules
in the past Legacy characters anyways
where I tried to stay away
um but I've been asked so many times
over and over again to to perform these
characters oh that must feel awesome
where you're like I ain't gonna touch
that and then they're like please yeah
yeah need somebody nobody can do it but
you where I've done and that's that's a
really good Roger Rabbit thank you I I
heard it uh you know I don't know what I
was doing but yeah you're gonna get
copyright strike now yeah but but yeah
like there have been moments where I've
actually backed away and turned down and
it was like literally like a couple like
a month or two had gone by and they're
like we're not We're not gonna work with
anyone we only want to work with you
does that mean like you could go well
I'll do it for another million well you
can come back and ask for more that's
not even like even in my mind at that
point it's just you're such an artist
for me it's still like the respect and
and kind of just like you know knowing
who was there before you and uh you know
but it's not up to me it's if I'd rather
I'd rather at that point I'm like well I
want to make it good at least like if
they're not gonna work with so and so
and they want to work with
you know someone like I'd rather it go
to someone that can execute well versus
like okay we're gonna settle on not that
person not that person but maybe that
person I'd rather just be okay look
you've tried we tried to work things out
clearly it's not working out I'll step
in and and do the job oh wow I have a
kind of hot question what's your
thoughts on uh the current
uh situation where really talented voice
actors are losing work to just
celebrities oh yeah I mean that's been
around for uh that's hot it's a hot it's
still a hot button issue and I thought
you're actually gonna go with authentic
casting too with like with racial
diversity and stuff since you're doing
Antonio Banderas but you're and I'm not
I'm not like authentically where he's
from yeah we do have Indian kid yeah
yeah Indian Ken so um that's amazing you
know like again I think with voice over
it's always it's never for me ever been
about like what you look like right
that's the beauty of it is that you can
walk into a room and not be six feet or
you could be too short or too tall for a
roll or too wide or that's what it's
called voice acting right yeah right
it's all about the ability to act with
your voice and not about what you look
like and
um there are definite cases where you
see a celebrity step into the role and
it's amazing and I think it'll for me it
really started with Robin Williams as
the genie you know like he was a
celebrity but he was not he was like a
card
he was amazing and like I think the the
but not everyone can do it Robin did you
know what I mean that's an anomaly you
know what I mean it's talented like they
they based everything either the design
of the character look like Robin so
which celebrity that stepped into voice
acting you're like [ __ ] this [ __ ] just
get them out it's even skillful it's
just obvious when like some folks phoned
it in uh like you could hear the phone
like the the other driving through
[Music]
just like that uh I like it when a a
celebrity comes in and they have uh you
know Tom Kenny was saying it the guy who
voices SpongeBob he's like there are
people that do character voices like
that like SpongeBob or people that have
voices with character so like someone
like Chris Rock or Eddie Murphy or or uh
Seth Rogen you know oh yeah they already
come with them like yeah something
unique Gilbert Godfrey yes fake I found
out it's all fake what's that he's he's
still alive he no he doesn't oh he's a
real voice he doesn't speak though right
right was it super chill I didn't know
that yeah but but you know it became so
but but you know what I think you
developed that on stage right with
stand-up yeah I think that was part of
it the SNL he didn't sound like that
yeah so I think it's like when they come
in with like something that is so
familiar that you're like oh it it works
you know like for the character like
Eddie Murphy is uh in Mulan you know as
the dragon Mushu so what would you do if
you did a take and then the director was
like can you do it more like this oh man
I mean there's there's been Chinese or
not yeah you don't sound like you're
pulling your eyes back enough uh you
know again it's it's authentic it's it's
great that's a great it's a hot hot tea
questions yeah uh where better
Vietnamese accents than Vietnamese
people do right so then you should get
hired for those video games where uh you
know I should be if there's never a
video game
um fighting Viet Cong That should be me
they're they're very well might be uh
and if they're not after they watch this
they're gonna make uh yeah but do you
just like draw the one line and go I'm
not gonna do that you yes it's up to you
and I think like I'll do it you know
it's crazy too it's like sometimes
they'll call for you like oh yeah like
we need a Filipino actor and then like
you go in there
and they're like don't do the accent
just do your normal voice you know then
why get a Filipino guy they just they
need to favor the uh say they could have
an accent yeah I know right I have a
Filipino Canadian accent yeah uh but
yeah it's it's crazy
to know now like people are now paying
attention to that you know the
authenticity in in not just the
Performing but I like that if we're
going that far down
there's authenticity in the storytelling
like if you're gonna write a story about
Filipinos growing up in La you better
get Filipinos they grew up in La that
had that experience you know yeah we're
totally out of time but last question
Bart loves uh would you rather [ __ ] your
mom or your dad all right I'm gonna go
with my brother because he's a mixture
of both so it's both
thank you for sharing
[Applause]
I'm here I was like who am I gonna [ __ ]
thank you
foreign